hi I'm Erik Bosse and we've been hearing
a lot recently about an upcoming Joker
movie or movies I should say rumor has
it there could be three the first being
a sequel to Suicide Squad with Jared
Leto reprising the role and with Will
Smith and Margot Robbie returning second
a joker spin-off with Leto and Robbie
exploring Joker's relationship with
Harley Quinn as of now directed by Crazy
Stupid Love directors glenn ficarra and
john requa and the third the one that
has gotten the most people talking a
rumored standalone non DCU origin story
for the Joker with director Todd
Phillips attached he made the hangover
movies also currently attached as
producer Martin Scorsese legendary
filmmaker of Goodfellas in the
department and yeah it's that third one
that again according to rumor they
approached Leonardo DiCaprio to play the
Joker now we should say that none of
these movies are even movies yet like no
scripts have been written these are all
just ideas and development based on
unconfirmed Hollywood gossip that we
really shouldn't read too much into no
no get that viscosity here I don't have
any but all of this does bring up the
very interesting question of what would
a great film about the Joker even look
like how do they get this right so we've
seen several adaptations of the Joker in
past films TV shows comics and graphic
novels animated series and video games
and the best versions of the Joker
overshadowed the story that they're
inside of they are iconic Jack Nicholson
received top billing as the Joker in Tim
Burton's Batman and it's hard to think
about the Dark Knight without seeing
Heath Ledger's face or Batman the
Animated Series without hearing mark
Hamill's voice first thing tomorrow I'm
sending a lovely case of cat food to
Batman
in fact I would argue that these three
Joker's left such a strong impression
that those stories weren't really Batman
stories as much as they were Joker
stories also these takes on the
characters seem to be driven by this
idea of calculated chaos yes they all
carry out complicated schemes and tricks
but it's never really clear what the end
goals of those plans are other than
complete disorder in that sense we don't
see these Joker's so much as men as much
as sadism and Anarchy embodied in human
form so with all this in mind let's
discuss two key elements that we would
want to see in any Joker movie that gets
made one eye
it should embrace the mystery of the
character so one of the rumors about
these upcoming Joker projects that has
gotten fans a little antsy is the idea
that one of them might be a Joker origin
story now the reason this is a little
controversial is that most modern takes
on the Joker are defined by the fact
that we don't know for sure what his
origin is so for example Heath Ledger's
Joker in the Dark Knight offered
conflicting accounts on the origin of
his scars I don't know what could
disguise my father was a drinker mommy
gets the kitchen knife to defend herself
he turns to me and he says why so
serious simple let's put a smile on that
face and a wife who gambles and gets in
deep with the sharks one day they carve
her face I just want to see her smile
again
I stick a razor in my mouth and do this
and towards the end of the movie he
starts to tell Batman a third origin
story before getting cut off and fan
theories have speculated that this Joker
could have been a former soldier based
on his expertise with explosives and the
line he says to Harvey Dent if tomorrow
I tell the press I'd like a gangbanger
will get shot or a truckload of soldiers
will be blowing up nobody panics because
it's all part of the plan Christopher
Nolan actually said that when conceiving
this version of the Joker he was
influenced by a few different literary
sources like Alan Moore's The Killing
Joke that graphic novel is considered by
many to be the best exploration of the
Joker's psychology and the Joker
actually does explain his origin story
in that a husband to a pregnant wife
financially struggling from a failed
comedy career who turns to a life of
crime to pay the bills and then goes
insane after an accident in a chemical
plant the animated movie version of The
Killing Joke followed this backstory too
but the thing is this whole origin is
told through the Joker's perspective in
fact Moore's dialogue gives us reason to
believe that he could be an unreliable
narrator lying about his past he
actually admits he has alternate
memories of a single event saying
sometimes I remember it one way
sometimes another I'm gonna have a past
I prefer it to be multiple choice even
more modern takes on the Joker had
followed this idea of reinvention DC had
Jeff John suggests
recently that there are actually three
Joker's in the rebirth comics which is
kind of crazy and I don't wanna go into
here but the takeaway from all this is
that origin stories are often better
left as a mystery The Joker is one of
the best pop-culture villains of all
time up there with Darth Vader and
Hannibal Lecter and I think we learn
from those other two villains origin
stories and it can feel a little
unsatisfying to see a villain get
created because in that case you
inevitably humanize them and you take
away their power as a threatening
character look I know it's human nature
to want to psychoanalyze everyone and
figure out what exactly makes them tick
but when it comes to great stories we
don't have to relate with and sympathize
every character sometimes characters can
just represent concepts that scare us
yeah some men can just want to watch the
world burn and that's okay now I do
think it's possible that a Joker origin
story film could avoid this kind of
humanization or a TMI backstory for
example imagine one that depicts the
Joker as sort of a Hannibal Lecter
figure locked up in Arkham Asylum
counseling a young Harleen Quinzel or
Batman or Nightwing or Robin as he
taunts them with possibly [ __ ]
origin stories as he plots his escape
guys I just want to see a movie with
like 20 different Joker origin stories
back to give each one to a different
director kind of like that anime got
them night anthology short story movie
did okay I'm getting too fan fiction me
here so let's move on to the other key
to making a great Joker film learn from
the best okay honestly whenever iconic
characters get rebooted or reimagined it
seems like there's this pressure to
reinvent the wheel there's a little
voice inside every filmmaker and actor
that tells us that people will think
were a hacker a plagiarist if we don't
try to be as new or as original as
possible but I don't think there's any
shame or hackery in recognizing the
decisions past artists have made that
we're extremely successful in trying to
follow in their footsteps
like sure Heath Ledger brought a unique
perspective of the Joker with his method
acting it's nuanced mannerisms and
grungy hair and makeup but I would say
the heart of his character was the
sadism and chaos and unpredictability
qualities that were explored long before
Leger ever got the role by people like
Alan Moore Neal Adams Danny O'Neil Bob
Kane and
yeah mark hamill and Jack Nicholson
meanwhile those two were clearly taking
inspiration from Cesar Romero's giddily
Insane Clown Prince of Crime in the 60s
now I actually kind of enjoyed Jared
Leto's version with a character in
Suicide Squad but I think he tried a
little too hard to replicate Ledger's
method approach to the character like
covering himself with punk tattoos and
mailing his co-stars [ __ ] Jared Leto
didn't need to reinvent the Joker Heath
Ledger didn't reinvent the Joker he and
Christopher Nolan just tapped into the
pre-established psychology of the
character that was most interesting to
explore now I've argued before how
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight is
largely successful because it follows
the plot points of Michael Mann's film
heat and I could get into how all the
nerd [ __ ] that we love the force awakens
Logan's stranger things work precisely
because they follow proven formulas of
classics and that doesn't make them
hacks it makes them smart but that is
another video all I'm saying here is
however Warner Brothers plans to adapt
the Joker in a new film I'm not gonna
complain if it looks a lot like
something we've seen before as long as
it's something we all loved like Silence
of the Lambs or if this does in the BNA
Scorsese DiCaprio joint a shudder island
Joker could be fun you know trippy
visuals an unreliable narrator a tragic
backstory that doesn't overly sympathize
with a character just think about it
also we don't need three different Joker
movies do we like one would be fine
right okay I have more opinions about
this than I thought so I'm gonna throw
it to you what do you want the Joker
movie to look like and if this DiCaprio
rumor is [ __ ] which it sounds likely
and they do replace Jared Leto who would
you want to see play this new Joker join
me in telling Hollywood film executives
how to do their jobs in the comments
below or tweet me directly at Yale or
new rock stars at new rockstars and
share this video and subscribe to new
rockstars to get all of our news about
DC movies and imaginary DC movies that
don't even exist yet and if you want you
can help us make more videos like this
by contributing to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current donors
especially Kristina Armstrong all right
thanks for watching bye